♪ ♪
>> Mark: AMERICA'S MIDDLE EAST
WARS HAVE COST TRILLIONS AND
PRODUCED NO BENEFITS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT AS CANDIDATE TRUMP LIKE TO
POINT OUT ON THE STUMP MAY NEVER
END.
ON SUNDAY THE U.S. CARRIED OUT
AIR STRIKES AIR STRIKES AGAINST
IRAQ HE MILITIA GROUP TIED TO
IRAN.
THE STRIKES CAME AFTER U.S.
CIVILIAN WAS KILLED IN A ROCKET
ATTACK.
THE IRAQ HE GOVERNMENT OBJECTED.
THE IRANIANS HAVE RESPONDED.
COULD THIS BE A STEP TOWARDS THE
WAR WITH IRAN THAT SO MANY OF
WASHINGTON'S FALLEN POLICY
ESTABLISHMENT ARE FOR?
DOUG IS A RETIRED -- AND THE
BOOK "MARGIN OF VICTORY" HE
JOINS US NOW.
COLONEL COME OFF OF A 19TH
CENTURY IMPERIALIST TO TAKE LORD
THOMAS' POSITION TO THE GREAT
CITIZENS KILLED WITH IMMUNITY
IMPUNITY, AND EXPECT TO REMAIN
UNGREAT, BUT WHAT IS THE BROADER
STRATEGIC OBJECTIVE IN THIS
CURRENT MILITARY ACTION?
>> WELL, GOOD EVENING, HE WAS A
SMART MAN.
HE SAID THAT GLADSTONE WOULD END
HIS POLITICAL CAREER IN A MAN
HOUSE AND HE WAS NOT FAR FROM
WRONG.
I THINK IF AMERICANS LOOK AT
THIS, THE FIRST QUESTION, WHAT
ARE WE DOING IN SYRIA, IRAQ,
WITH TROOPS ON THE GROUND?
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE TO BEGIN
WITH?
I DON'T THINK THAT HAS BEEN
FULLY EXPLAINED.
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD ROUTINELY, WE
ARE COMING OUT, WE ARE COMING
OUT, WE ARE COMING OUT.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO BE
SUBVERTED AND WE END UP WITH A
FEW MORE TROOPS LEFT.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE.
IT MAY EXPLAIN WHAT WAS DONE ON
SUNDAY.
THIS CONTRACTOR WAS KILLED IN
THIS ROCKET ATTACK IN THE
VICINITY OF A PLACE CALLED KEIRA
COOK.
NOW COME IF YOU LOOK AT THE FIVE
TARGETS, THREE INSIDE A RACK AND
TWO IN SYRIA, THESE TARGETS ARE
250 MILES, 300 MILES AWAY FROM
KEIRA COOK.
SO WE ARE NOT STRIKING ANYTHING
IN THE VICINITY WHERE THIS EVENT
HAPPENED.
SECONDLY, ALL OF THESE TARGETS,
YES THEY ARE PART OF WHAT WE
CALLED THE PMF POPULAR MOBILIZED
FOR US, THEY ARE A RAINY AND
TRADE, SHIITE MILITIA AND THEY
HAVE BEEN KILLING ISIS.
AND AL QAEDA.
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY LIBERATED AND
PROTECTED CHRISTIANS FROM OUR
FRIENDS IN ISIS.
ISIS IS LARGELY GONE, BUT THEY
ARE STILL DIGGING THEM OUT IN
LOWER SYRIA.
FOR SOME REASON WE CHOSE TO
STRIKE ALL OF THESE TARGETS
INSTEAD OF LOOKING FOR SOMETHING
IN THE VICINITY OF HERE.
IT SEEMS SUSPICION IS PROBABLY
ACCURATE.
IT LOOKS LIKE AN ATTEMPT TO DRAG
US INTO SOMETHING.
>> Mark: LET ME JUST ASK YOU
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU BASICALLY
SAID THAT THESE GUYS WERE
FIGHTING ISIS HERE THE LAST TIME
ANY OF US GAVE ANY ATTENTION TO
THEM.
SO THEY WERE THE ENEMY OF OUR
ENEMY.
BUT IT COMES OUT THAT THEY ARE
ALSO OUR ENEMY.
WE ARE JUST TOURISTS IN THE
HEART OF DARKNESS STAGGERING
AROUND FROM ONE BARELY
UNDERSTOOD FACTION TO ANOTHER?
>> I THINK STAGGERING AROUND
FROM ONE MISUNDERSTOOD
PERFECTION TO IT THE NEXT IS A
GOOD DESCRIPTION.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY IDEA
WHAT WE ARE DOING THEY ARE AND I
THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
SKILLFULLY MISINFORMED.
I THINK HE IS BEING WALKED INTO
ANOTHER AMBUSH AS MUCH AS HE WAS
LAST SUMMER WHEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
HE WAS PRESENTED WITH WHAT SHOT
DOWN A GLOBAL -- WE HAVE TO
ATTACK IRAN.
NOW WE HAVE ATTACKED A RAINY
IMPACT FORCES, THE IRAQ HE
GOVERNMENT I THINK WE'LL TRY TO
THROW US OUT IN THE PARLIAMENT
HAS VOTED UNANIMOUSLY FOR US TO
LEAVE, SO I THINK THE NEXT STEP
IS FOR THE IRAQ HE IS TO SAY GET
OUT.
I DON'T THINK THE IRANIANS OR
IRAQIS WILL NECESSARILY RESPOND
IN THE WAY THAT THEY WOULD HOPE.
>> Mark: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
ALWAYS SAID HE THOUGHT THESE
WARS WERE A COMPLETE WASTE OF
TIME.
THEY HAVE GONE ON FOR
GENERATIONS, BUT IN EFFECT, THE
QUESTION IS, HAS HE BECOME
CAPTIVE OF THE BUSH ERA FOREIGN
POLICY AND WHO WANTED IN AND OUT
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION?
JUST QUICKLY.
>> IF HE IS NOT THE CAPTIVE, HE
CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE IT.
HE IS THE ONLY THING STANDING
BETWEEN US AND ANOTHER POINTLESS
WAR.
HE IS THE ONE CAN SAY NO AND HE
DOES.